Speaking of psychology is taking a summer break, so we're rerunning one of our favorite episodes from the past. Last August, I talked to psychologist Eva Tells her about what scientists are learning about the teen brain, why teens take more risks, and why that risk-taking can lead to benefits as well as harms. We hope you enjoy this episode from the archives. Speaking of Psychology, we'll be back with new episodes on August 23rd. Thank you for listening. There may be no stage in life that's more maligned than adolescence. When people think of teenagers, the words that may come to mind include moody, impulsive,
《心理学话题》正在过暑假，所以我们将重播过去最受欢迎的一期节目。去年八月，我采访了心理学家伊娃·特尔泽，探讨了科学家对青少年大脑的新发现、青少年为何更倾向于冒险，以及这种冒险行为如何既带来益处又带来危害。希望大家喜欢这期来自档案库的节目。《心理学话题》将于8月23日携全新节目回归。感谢您的收听。也许生命中没有哪个阶段比青春期更受诋毁了。当人们想到青少年时，脑海中浮现的词汇可能包括：喜怒无常、冲动、
risk-taking, and self-centered. In the movies on TV and in our imaginations, teenagers drive too fast, they experiment with drugs and alcohol, and they cave to peer pressure to take other unwise risks. Looking back, many of us probably remember doing a few of those things ourselves when we were teens. And teenage brains, so the stereotype goes, are driving these actions. These brains just haven't developed enough for young people to make good decisions. But researchers are increasingly finding that this negative view of the adolescent brain is inaccurate and incomplete.
爱冒险、以自我为中心。在电影、电视以及我们的想象中，青少年开车太快，尝试毒品和酒精，并且屈服于同辈压力去冒其他不明智的险。回过头来看，我们许多人可能也记得自己在青少年时期做过其中一些事情。而刻板印象认为，青少年的大脑正是这些行为的幕后推手。这些大脑还没有充分发育，以至于年轻人无法做出明智的决定。但研究人员越来越发现，这种对青少年大脑的负面看法是不准确且不完整的。
Yes, teenagers are still a work in progress, but the brain changes that mark adolescents make at a time of great opportunity and growth as well as risk. So what is happening in the teenage brain? Do adolescents take more risks than other age groups and is that risk taking always bad? Who has more influence over teens' behavior, their parents or their peers? Are teens really more self-centered than adults? And how might social media and other technology use be changing teens' behavior and development? Welcome to Speaking of Psychology, the flagship podcast of the American Psychological Association that examines the links between psychological science and everyday life.
是的，青少年仍然在成长中，但标志着青春期的那些大脑变化，也让他们迎来了机遇与成长并存、同时伴随风险的时期。那么，青少年的大脑究竟发生了什么？与其他年龄段相比，青少年真的冒更多险吗？这种冒险总是坏事吗？谁对青少年行为的影响更大：父母还是同伴？青少年真的比成年人更以自我为中心吗？社交媒体和其他科技产品的使用又将如何改变青少年的行为和发展？欢迎收听《心理学话题》，这是美国心理学会的旗舰播客，旨在探讨心理科学与日常生活之间的联系。
I'm Kim Mills. My guest today is Dr. Eva Telzer, an associate professor of psychology and neuroscience at the University of North Carolina Chapel Hill. She studies teens' brain development and behavior with a focus on risk-taking, family and peer relationships, pro-social behavior, and long-term psychological well-being. She's also interested in how social media and technology
我是金·米尔斯。我今天的嘉宾是北卡罗来纳大学教堂山分校的心理学和神经科学副教授伊娃·特尔泽博士。她研究青少年的大脑发育和行为，重点关注冒险行为、家庭与同伴关系、亲社会行为以及长期的心理健康。她还对社交媒体和科技
are affecting teens' brain development. And she is the co-director of the Winston National Center on technology use, brain, and psychological development. She's received many awards for her work, including APA's Boyd-McCandless Award for Early Career Contributions to Developmental Psychology, and the Association's Distinguished Scientific Award for Early Career Contributions to Psychology. Thank you for joining us today, Dr. Telzer.
如何影响青少年的大脑发育感兴趣。此外，她还是温斯顿国家科技使用、大脑与心理发展中心的主任。她的研究工作获得了许多奖项，包括美国心理学会（APA）颁发的旨在表彰早期发展心理学贡献的博伊德-麦坎德利斯奖，以及该学会颁发的杰出青年心理学贡献科学奖。特尔泽博士，非常感谢您今天做客我们的节目。
Thank you so much for having me. Let's start with a definition so that we're on the same page in terms of what age group we're talking about. In your research, how do you define Adelior? lessons, is it just the teenage years from 13 to 19, or does it encompass a broader range? So defining adolescence is quite complicated. It is not necessarily defined by age. It's not necessarily defined by other markers such as the onset and offset of puberty. And so when we study adolescence, we often are following youth across time to look at change. And we typically
非常感谢邀请我。让我们从一个定义开始，以便我们在讨论的年龄段上达成共识。在您的研究中，您如何定义青少，年？这仅仅是指13到19岁的青少年时期，还是涵盖了更广的范围？所以，定义青春期相当复杂。它不一定是由年龄来定义的。它也不一定由青春期的开始和结束等其他标志来定义。因此，当我们研究青春期时，我们通常会跨时间追踪年轻人以观察变化。我们通常从
start in middle school. So six and seventh graders in the United States, for example, and following them through the end of high school. So 12th grade in the United States, sometimes our research starts a little bit younger and sometimes goes a little bit older. For the most part, we're studying adolescents from approximately sixth grade to 12th grade. So one of the most common negative stereotypes about teens is that they take a lot of unnecessary and unwise risks and that this risk-taking tendency is wired into their brains. How accurate is that? Are teens more prone to take risks compared with adults and even younger children? Yeah, so there's a fair amount of research looking at risk-taking behaviors and how this might change across development. So following
初中开始。例如，在美国是六年级和七年级学生，并一直追踪到高中结束。也就是美国的十二年级，有时我们的研究开始得稍微早一点，有时结束得稍微晚一点。总的来说，我们研究的青少年大约从六年级到十二年级。那么，关于青少年最常见的负面刻板印象之一是，他们承担了许多不必要且不明智的风险，并且这种冒险倾向是他们大脑天生固有的。这种说法有多准确？与成年人甚至更小的儿童相比，青少年是否更容易冒险？是的，有相当多的研究探讨了冒险行为以及这种行为在发展过程中可能如何变化。因此，通过追踪
youth, starting in childhood through adolescence to adulthood, and even doing this work across nationally, researchers have found what looks like an inverted U-shaped pattern with adolescents showing the highest levels of risk-taking behaviors. So this ranges from behaviors that might be construed as negative, like, substance use behaviors, but also less risky behaviors. So on an experimental task, for example, where you can manipulate rewards that they might receive, but a risk of not getting that reward, we can see that adolescents more so than children and more so than adults choose to take the risk in order to receive that reward. And this is thought
从儿童期、青春期到成年期的年轻人，甚至跨国开展这项工作，研究人员发现了一种类似于倒U型的模式，其中青少年的冒险行为水平最高。这不仅包括可能被解释为负面的行为，例如物质使用行为，还包括风险较低的行为。例如，在实验任务中，你可以操纵他们可能获得的奖励，但同时也存在得不到该奖励的风险，我们可以看到，与儿童和成年人相比，青少年更倾向于冒风险以获得该奖励。人们认为，这
to be driven by sensation-seeking and reward-seeking behaviors that are substantiated in the brain. So there's quite a bit of research out there showing that an area of the brain called the ventral striatum, which codes for reward value, is more activated in adolescence when they receive rewards and when they take risks, then this brain region is activated in children or adults. So it is true based on the empirical research out there that adolescents are more likely to take risks and that there is evidence from the brain that supports why this might be happening. So it's perhaps driven by this tendency to seek out rewards. But the widely held stereotype that this is very negative and drives only negative behavior,
是由大脑中得到证实的寻求刺激和寻求奖励的行为驱动的。因此，有相当多的研究表明，大脑中一个被称为纹状体腹侧的区域（它对奖励价值进行编码）在青少年获得奖励和冒险时比在儿童或成年人身上被激活得更强烈。因此，根据现有的实证研究，青少年更有可能冒险，并且有来自大脑的证据支持这一现象发生的原因。因此，这可能是由这种寻求奖励的倾向所驱动的。但是，那种认为这完全是负面的并且只会驱动负面行为的广泛流传的刻板印象，
like teens recklessly driving or jumping off a bridge or doing other more negative risks may be overstated because teens are engaging in so many positive risks that are sometimes overlooked in the media as well as parents worried about what teens might be doing with their peers, for example. And so there's lots of risks that might be construed as more positive. So, for example, if you're in a class and the teacher raises a question, some teens may feel very nervous about raising their hand and answering the question. But you might do so. You might raise your hand and answer the question, even if you're kind of afraid of your peers thinking poorly of you or not getting the answer right. And so that's just one example of a positive risk. There's also what we define as a pro-social risk.
比如青少年鲁莽驾驶、从桥上跳下或进行其他更具负面性的冒险，可能被夸大了，因为青少年正在参与如此多的积极冒险，而这些冒险有时在媒体中被忽视了，父母也会担心青少年在同伴中可能会做什么，等等。因此，有很多冒险可能被解释为更具积极性。例如，如果你在课堂上，老师提出一个问题，有些青少年可能会对举手回答问题感到非常紧张。但你还是会这么做。你可能会举手回答问题，即使你有点害怕同伴对你有不好的看法，或者害怕答错。这只是积极冒险的一个例子。还有我们所定义的亲社会风险。
So this is going out of your way, potentially risking social status or other types of risks that may come with some backlash in order to help somebody else. So as an example, there might be a kid getting bullied in school. And so a pro-social risk would be standing up to the bully and helping out that kid who's being bullied. And so there is this potentially huge risk that the bully is going to backlash at you or that your social status. You may be viewed more negatively by some of the cool kids in school. But the potential positive of this is helping out that kid who might be getting bullied. So you mentioned an area of the brain that's activated, right, which is why some teens may be taking risk. Does the same thing happen in adults?
因此，为了帮助他人，你可能会付出额外的努力，潜在地冒着牺牲社交地位或伴随某种强烈反对的其他类型风险的代价。举个例子，学校里可能会有一个孩子遭到霸凌。那么，亲社会风险就是挺身而出对抗霸凌者，并帮助那个被霸凌的孩子。因此，这里存在着巨大的潜在风险，即霸凌者会报复你，或者你的社交地位受损。你可能会被学校里的一些酷小孩以更负面的眼光看待。但这样做的潜在积极意义是帮助了那个可能遭到霸凌的孩子。所以，你提到了大脑中被激活的一个区域，对吧，这就是为什么有些青少年可能会冒险的原因。成年人身上也会发生同样的情况吗？
And how is it that adults can regulate that? So there is heightened ventral stride and activation in adults, too, when they engage in risks and receive reward. It's just not as high as it is in adolescent. So there's thought to be less of this reward drive in adults. There's what is now thought to be a relatively simplified view of the development of reward seeking and risk taking behavior, which is not necessarily robustly supported in the research, which I think you're alluding to, which is this idea of, which is this idea of, regulation where adults are better regulated, have a more developed prefrontal cortex, and therefore they can downregulate that ventral striatum response. But that's not necessarily the full story here. Adolescents actually are very good at regulating their behavior. They have not a broken brain or undeveloped prefrontal cortex, but a regulatory system that's very flexible and can be engaged to meet their motivational goals. And so it's not that they can can't regulate their behavior. It's just that sometimes their goal is not to regulate their
成年人又是如何调节这种行为的呢？是的，成年人在进行冒险和接受奖励时，腹侧纹状体的激活程度也会升高。只是没有青少年那么高。因此，人们认为成年人的这种奖励驱动力较小。现在人们对寻求奖励和冒险行为的发展有一个相对简化的看法，这种看法在研究中不一定得到强有力的支持，我想你指的就是这个，也就是这种关于调节的观点，即成年人的调节能力更好，拥有更发达的前额叶皮层，因此他们可以下调腹侧纹状体的反应。但这不一定是故事的全部。事实上，青少年非常擅长调节自己的行为。他们的大脑并没有损坏，前额叶皮层也没有发育不全，而是拥有一个非常灵活的调节系统，可以用来实现他们的动机目标。因此，并不是说他们无法调节自己的行为。只是有时他们的目标不是调节自己的
behavior because the reward of one behavior just may be much more highly valued than the reward of regulating that behavior. And so they choose to engage in it. It's not that they are incapable of not stopping themselves from engaging in it. There's an idea that the teenagers are egged on by their peers to take risks and that their parents don't have a whole lot of influence over them at this point in life. What have you found in your research to parents or peers have more influence when it comes to teens risk taking? Yeah, so there is absolutely this stereotype out there that peers are going to drive adolescents to engage in largely negative behaviors and that parents have less of a role in affecting their teens' decision making. And what's
行为，因为某种行为的奖励可能比调节这种行为的奖励更有价值。所以他们选择参与其中。并不是说他们没有能力阻止自己不参与其中。有一种观点认为，青少年是在同伴的怂恿下才去冒险的，而且在这个人生阶段，父母对他们的影响并不大。你在研究中发现，在青少年冒险方面，到底是父母还是同伴的影响更大？是的，绝对存在这样一种刻板印象，即同伴会驱使青少年参与绝大多数负面行为，而父母在影响青少年决策方面所起的作用较小。而令人
remarkable is that there's really been no research to support this and not a lot of of research out there has even been done to ask this very question. And so we have completed several studies now in my lab to look at the relative role of parent and peer influence on adolescents' risk-taking behaviors, as well as their more positive types of behaviors, like pro-social behaviors or healthy behaviors. And what we have found is across multiple studies now, either parents and peers have a similar influence on adolescence decision-making or parents actually outweigh that of their peers. In one study, for example, adolescents had a decision to take a risk or not in the presence of conflicting information from their parent and their peers. So their parent may have said,
注目的是，实际上没有任何研究支持这一点，也没有进行过多少研究来探讨这个具体问题。因此，我的实验室现在已经完成了几项研究，旨在探讨父母和同伴对青少年冒险行为的相对影响，以及他们对亲社会行为或健康行为等更积极行为的相对影响。我们通过多项研究发现，要么父母和同伴对青少年决策的影响相似，要么父母的影响实际上超过了同伴。例如，在一项研究中，青少年在父母和同伴提供冲突信息的情况下，面临着是否冒险的决定。也就是说，他们的父母可能说：
take the risk, and their peer may have said, no, play it safe, and vice versa. And what we find is that teens are more likely to go along with what their parent says than with what their peer says in this risk-taking context. In other studies, for example, looking at their risk, attitudes and their pro-social attitudes, we find that teens go along with their parents' attitudes and their peers' attitudes at about a 50-50 level. So they're just as likely to follow what their parents' attitudes are as they are to follow what their peers' attitudes are. And what's actually quite striking is that they stick with their own attitudes more often than they go along with what their parents or their peers think. And so,
去冒险吧，而他们的同伴可能会说：不，稳妥点，反之亦然。我们发现，在这种冒险情境下，青少年更有可能听从父母的话，而不是同伴的话。在其他研究中，例如考察他们的风险态度和亲社会态度，我们发现青少年顺从父母态度和同伴态度的比例大约各占百分之五十。也就是说，他们听从父母态度的可能性与听从同伴态度的可能性是一样的。而实际上非常引人注目的是，他们坚持自己态度的频率，要高于他们顺从父母或同伴看法的频率。因此，
Rather than being overly susceptible to what other people think in their social environment, especially their peers, adolescents are actually kind of sticking to their guns more often than they are to follow what their peers think or even what their parents think. And we think that this is quite remarkable compared to the overall stereotype that teens are overly susceptible to others. and actually teens kind of are independent thinkers and stick with what they think are positive and negative behaviors more so than they are to go along with others. You've found that risk taking can be adaptive in development. What do you mean by that? How does risk taking essentially help young people grow and develop? So there's lots of different ways that risk taking can be adaptive.
与社会环境中其他人（尤其是同伴）的看法相比，青少年并没有过度受其左右，相反，青少年在坚持自己主见方面的频率要高于盲从同伴甚至父母看法的情况。与青少年过度易受他人影响的整体刻板印象相比，我们认为这相当了不起。事实上，青少年某种程度上是独立的思想者，他们坚持自己认为积极和消极的行为，而不是随波逐流。你发现冒险在发展过程中可以具有适应性。你这是什么意思？冒险究竟如何帮助年轻人成长和发展？所以冒险有很多不同的适应性方式。
One is that just from an evolutionary perspective, going out, learning from your environment, engaging in kind of flexible behaviors, trial and error helps adolescents to learn and develop and explore who they are and what matters to them. It allows them to make new friends to get away from the family and find a mate. So sort of from that kind of evolutionary perspective, it promotes development. There's also adaptive ways that it can happen just in terms of these more positive risks that I alluded to earlier, raising your hand in class, or asking your crush out on a date,
其中之一是，仅从进化的角度来看，走出去，从环境中学习，参与某种灵活的行为、反复试错，有助于青少年学习、发展并探索他们是谁以及什么对他们重要。这能让他们结交新朋友、脱离家庭并找到伴侣。因此，从这种进化角度来看，它促进了发展。此外，正如我前面提到的那些更积极的冒险（比如在课堂上举手，或者邀请暗恋的人出去约会），
or trying out for a challenging sports activity or something else that might be challenging that you might be scared to do, but kind of taking the risk to try it are all ways that risks can be highly adaptive in adolescence. Now, you've tackled another stereotype in your research, which is that teens are more self-centered than adults. That's a pretty common idea. But as you've pointed out, there's a countervailing stereotype that many teens are driven to change the world for the better. I mean, a lot of the big social movements of our time from climate change to Black Lives Matter have been led in part by adolescents. So how do these ideas fit together?
或者尝试一项具有挑战性的体育活动或其他可能让你害怕的挑战，但敢于冒险去尝试，这些都是冒险在青春期具有高度适应性的表现。现在，你在研究中打破了另一个刻板印象，即青少年比成年人更以自我为中心。这是一个非常普遍的观点。但正如你所指出的，存在一种相反的刻板印象，即许多青少年有动力让世界变得更美好。我的意思是，我们这个时代的许多重大社会运动，从气候变化到“黑人的命也是命”，部分都是由青少年领导的。那么这些观点是如何契合在一起的呢？
Are teens more self-centered than adults? or are they more idealistic and driven to do more good in the world? Adolescence, I think, is just such a remarkable developmental period. So for all of the reasons that the brain is developing and changing and thought to be negative are many of the reasons that adolescents are engaging in really positive behavior. So, for example, increases in the ventral stratum that I discussed earlier that is related to reward value and feeling good are increasing during adolescence. At the same time, brain regions involved in social perspective taking are increasing.
青少年比成年人更以自我为中心吗？还是他们更具理想主义，更有动力在世界上做好事？我认为青春期是一个非常了不起的发展阶段。大脑发育、改变并被认为具有负面影响的种种原因，恰恰也是青少年参与非常积极行为的许多原因。例如，我之前讨论过的与奖励价值和良好感觉相关的腹侧纹状体在青春期增加。与此同时，涉及社会透视采纳（social perspective taking）的大脑区域也在增加。
And these together, I think, really promote the ability of adolescents to engage in really meaningful activities that bring them joy, so that reward sensitivity, while also taking the perspective of others and thinking about the broader societal needs of their community. And so we see that adolescents, as you mentioned, are engaging in really positive behaviors during this period. They're leading social movements. They're also doing this at a smaller scale, whether that be contributing to their family or helping their friends or volunteering at their local community. Some teens do this at such a huge level. So leading the climate change movements, leading these bigger scale movement that have gotten,
我认为，这些因素结合在一起，真正促进了青少年参与那些能给他们带来快乐的非常有意义的活动的能力，也就是这种对奖励的敏感性，同时也考虑了他人的观点并思考了社区更广泛的社会需求。因此我们看到，正如你所提到的，青少年在这个时期正在参与非常积极的行为。他们在领导社会运动。他们也在较小的规模上这样做，无论是为家庭做贡献、帮助朋友还是在当地社区做志愿者。有些青少年在如此宏大的层面上这样做。比如领导气候变化运动，领导这些吸引了成千上万人的更大规模的运动，但这并不非得在那个规模上发生。青少年在日常生活中也在进行亲社会和以社区为导向的活动。他们这样做不仅是为了考上大学之类的，而且研究表明，参与奖励敏感性和社会敏感性的这些大脑区域被激活了，这表明参与这些活动确实能给他们带来快乐，
gotten tons and tons of people involved, but it doesn't have to happen at that scale. And adolescents in their everyday lives are doing activities that are pro-social and community-oriented. And they're not doing this just to like get into college, for example, but there's research showing that these brain regions involved in reward sensitivity and social sensitivity are activated, suggesting that it really does bring them joy to engage in this. and it is a meaningful activity for adolescents. How does culture affect teens' experiences of adolescents? Do teens in different countries show similar changes in behavior and brain development during
这对青少年来说是一项有意义的活动。文化如何影响青少年对青春期的体验？在你研究的这些年里，不同国家的青少年在行为和大脑发育方面表现出相似的变化吗？在某种程度上，青春期是一种社会建构。因此，你所生活的社会决定了如何看待青春期。因此，对青少年的刻板印象是由我们生活的文化决定的。在某些文化中，青春期被描述为
the years that you study? In a way, adolescent is a social construction. And so the society that you live in determines how adolescence is viewed. So the stereotypes of adolescents are determined by the culture we live in. In some cultures, adolescence is discreet. as a time of risk-taking and this storm and stress, which was one of the very original ways of describing adolescents. And some cultures don't view it in that way. And what's really interesting is that in the way that one's culture views adolescence, oftentimes adolescence
冒险和疾风怒涛（storm and stress）的时期，这是描述青春期的最初方式之一。而有些文化则不这样看。真正有趣的是，由于人们的文化看待青春期的方式不同，青春期的体验往往也
is experienced in those ways. So there has been cross-cultural research. For example, young Hugh, who's now an assistant professor at Northwestern, has done. done research in China and the United States to look at how these stereotypes of adolescents are different. And they differ in China and they differ in the United States. And China adolescents is viewed less so at this time of risk-taking and peer influence and more so as this time of family obligation and educational motivation than, for example, in the U.S. And so there's definitely ways in which the culture that we live in can affect how adolescents are viewed. And what's important to keep in mind is that these stereotypes and views of
会以这些方式呈现。因此，有过跨文化研究。例如，现在是西北大学助理教授的年轻休（Young Hu，音译）曾在中国和美国开展研究，以观察这些对青少年的刻板印象有何不同。它们在中国和美国有所不同。与美国相比，在中国，青春期较少被视为一个充满冒险和同辈影响的时期，而更多地被视为一个充满家庭义务和教育动机的时期。因此，我们生活的文化绝对可以通过多种方式影响人们对青少年的看法。需要牢记的一点是，这些刻板印象和对
adolescents are often self-fulfilling prophecies. So if I grow up in a culture that views adolescence as this time of risk-taking, I'm more likely to think that adolescence is a time of risk-taking and therefore engage in more risk-taking because I think that that's what adolescents are supposed to do. And so there's definitely ways in which culture impacts. just the mere experience of what adolescence is described as the stereotypes that are endorsed by that group and how adolescents growing up in that culture might view and experience adolescents themselves. What about differences between the sexes? A lot of people say that girls are more mature than boys, that they are more sensible than their male counterparts. Do girls take fewer risks,
青少年的看法往往是自我实现的预言。因此，如果我在一个将青春期视为冒险时期的文化中长大，我就更有可能认为青春期就是冒险的时期，因此会参与更多的冒险，因为我认为这才是青少年应该做的。因此，文化绝对会以各种方式影响青春期的体验本身，影响该群体所赞同的刻板印象，以及在那种文化中长大的青少年如何看待和体验青春期本身。性别之间的差异呢？很多人说女孩比男孩更成熟，她们比同龄的男孩更懂事。女孩冒的险更少吗？
or is this a groundless belief or do they take different types of risks? Yeah, that's a great question that I don't have the full answer for. But the short answer just from our work is that we don't find gender differences. Boys and girls don't differ in the amount of risks they take. I think we need more well-powered studies. And by that, I mean large sample sizes that look at risk-taking across many different behaviors to get a better sense of whether girls and boys might, differ in the types of risks that they take. There are in the literature out there, I'm less
还是这是一个毫无根据的信念，或者她们冒险的类型不同？是的，这是一个很好的问题，但我没有全面的答案。但仅从我们的研究来看，简短的回答是，我们没有发现性别差异。男孩和女孩在冒险的数量上没有区别。我认为我们需要更多样本量充足的研究。我的意思是，需要有大的样本量来观察跨多种不同行为的冒险情况，以便更好地了解女孩和男孩在冒险类型上是否可能存在差异。文献中确实存在一些我不太
versed with it, so don't want to say too much, but there is some evidence that girls and boys might differ in terms of externalizing behaviors, for example. But I think that girls and boys actually are more similar to each other than they are different, and that the variability is really within these groups of adolescents. So it will range across girls as much as it'll range across boys. Do you know whether there are differences based on race and ethnicity or socioeconomic status? You could imagine that somebody who is living in a tougher situation, you might be willing to take more risks because, you know, what do I have to lose here? Right? My life is already tough. Yes, there's definitely evidence, especially when it comes to socioeconomic,
熟悉的证据，所以不想说太多，但确实有一些证据表明，例如在外部化行为方面，女孩和男孩可能会有所不同。但我认为女孩和男孩其实大同小异，差异主要存在于这些青少年群体内部。女孩内部的差异范围与男孩内部的差异范围一样大。你知道是否存在基于种族、族裔或社会经济地位的差异吗？你可以想象，生活在更艰难环境中的人可能愿意冒更多的风险，因为，你知道，我在这里还有什么可失去的呢？对吧？我的生活已经很艰难了。是的，确实有证据，特别是在社会经济
status that teens from lower SCIS environments are more likely to take risks and engage in externalizing behaviors for exactly the point you raise that, like, what is there to lose? Or actually, maybe there's something really to gain by engaging that's risk-taking. So if my family can't afford to put food on the table, I might go out and steal or engage in other behaviors in order to help my family. And that's considered a huge risk, but it may actually be in that. and the outcome is helpful for them and their family. Or being exposed to an environment that has lots of risks and negative experiences in the
地位方面，来自较低社会经济地位环境的青少年更有可能冒险并参与外部化行为，原因正如你所提出的，那就是：有什么好失去的？或者实际上，通过冒险可能会获得很多东西。因此，如果我的家庭负担不起饭菜，我可能会出去偷窃或从事其他行为来帮助我的家庭。这被认为是一个巨大的风险，但实际上对他们和他们的家庭来说，结果可能是有帮助的。或者暴露在一个充满风险和负面经验的
environment, whether you're growing up in a place with a lot of violence or being exposed to other things. There's instances where either taking a risk is a good thing or taking a risk is something that is socialized within that environment because of what you're exposed to. When it comes to ethnic racial differences, the literature is much more mixed. And so there's not kind of clear differences there.
环境中，无论你是在一个充满暴力的环境中长大，还是暴露在其他事物中。在某些情况下，要么冒险是一件好事，要么冒险是由于你所接触的事物而在该环境中被社会化接受的一种行为。当谈到种族和族裔差异时，文献的结论要杂乱得多。因此，那里没有明确的差异。
I think, again, similar to boys and girls, there's more similarities than there are differences. And the differences are not at all due to anything that's like biologically wired that's different between racial or ethnic groups, but perhaps something that is culturally socialized if there are differences that are In our culture, we have kind of prolonged adolescence. I mean, you know, we've, kids are living with their parents longer for economic and for other reasons. You know, we're really sort of, in a sense, you might say, you know, we've been coddling our kids. Is that having an impact
我认为，再次与男孩和女孩类似，相似之处多于差异。这些差异根本不是由于种族或族裔群体之间存在任何生物学上的差异，而是如果存在差异的话，也许是某种文化社会化带来的。在我们的文化中，我们有某种延长的青春期。我的意思是，你知道，由于经济和其他原因，孩子们和父母住在一起的时间更长了。你知道，从某种意义上说，你可能会说，你知道，我们在溺爱孩子。这会对他们的
on their desire to take risks there and risks that might be good for them? Yeah. So in either societies where kids have to grow up sooner or for other reasons where you might have to grow up sooner. For example, if you don't have lots of resources or parents who are available and, for example, if you're in the foster system and don't have a mom and dad necessarily to support you well past 18, you might have to grow up sooner. Whereas for teens in higher SDS environments, or for those who do have parents who one can live with for longer past the high school years when you're technically defined by society to be an adult, this provides an opportunity to kind of grow up slower. In a lot of ways, this can be positive. There's research from both
冒险渴望产生影响吗？这种冒险可能对他们有好处吗？是的。在孩子们不得不更早长大的社会里，或者出于其他原因，你可能不得不更早长大。例如，如果你没有大量的资源或可以随时提供帮助的父母，例如如果你处于寄养系统（foster system）中，在18岁以后不一定有爸爸妈妈来很好地支持你，你可能就必须更早长大。然而，对于处于较高社会经济地位环境中的青少年，或者对于那些确实有父母可以与之同住更长时间（超过了社会技术上定义的成年人的高中毕业年龄）的青少年来说，这提供了一个稍微晚一点长大的机会。在很多方面，这可能是积极的。来自
animal models and actually human models showing that the brain slows down in development when given the opportunity to, but speeds up and becomes more mature sooner in environments where you kind of have to grow up sooner. And both are adaptive. You're adapting to the environment to which you need to either grow up sooner or have more opportunity to explore your environment. And so by prolonging adolescence, we're giving teens the opportunity to explore more, explore their identity, explore different opportunities for who they want to be when they grow up, engage in different types of risks that might be very adaptive for reaching those goals. And so if you're in an environment that allows you to kind of slow down that process of developing
动物模型和人类模型的研究都表明，当有此机会时，大脑的发育会放慢，但在那些你不得不更早长大的环境中，大脑会加速发育并更早成熟。两者都是具适应性的。你正在适应需要你更早长大或拥有更多机会探索环境的环境。因此，通过延长青春期，我们给了青少年更多探索的机会，探索他们的身份认同，探索他们长大后想成为什么样的人的不同机会，并参与有助于实现这些目标的各种类型的冒险。因此，如果你身处一个能够让你放慢这种成长过程的环境中，
growing up, then it's perhaps a positive thing for youth and not something that we necessarily need to look down on. Like they're just not growing up and they're staying teenagers forever and they're not getting married and having kids until later. Maybe this is a positive thing that allows them to really explore and define who they are and make decisions that are going to be the best for them as they reach adulthood. Now, you also study teens and technology and social media use. and I know you're interested not only in how it's affecting their social and emotional lives, but how it might be shaping their brain development. Can you talk about that?
那么这对年轻人来说可能是一件积极的事情，而不是我们必然需要看低的事情。好像他们只是没有长大，永远留在青少年时期，直到很晚才结婚生子。也许这是一件积极的事情，能让他们真正探索和定义自己，并在步入成年时做出对他们来说最好的决定。现在，你还研究了青少年、科技和社交媒体的使用。我知道你不仅对它如何影响他们的社会和情感生活感兴趣，还对它如何塑造他们的大脑发育感兴趣。你能谈谈这个吗？
What are the questions you're trying to answer by looking at this particular situation? Yeah, so social media has really, I think, changed the social landscape of what adolescence looks like today compared to, for example, when I was a teenager and had to see my peers either in person or talk to them on the phone in order to interact with them. There's this around-the-clock ability to engage either synchronously or asynchronously. And by that, I mean, you can be texting back and forth into the wee hours of the night. You can be scrolling through social media and putting up comments and getting likes and getting feedback on that very quickly.
通过观察这种特定情况，你想回答什么问题？是的，我认为社交媒体真正改变了当今青少年的社交格局，例如，与我还是个青少年、必须亲自见到同伴或在电话里与他们交谈才能进行互动时相比。现在有一种全天候的同步或异步互动能力。我的意思是，你可以一直发短信到深夜。你可以滚动浏览社交媒体，发表评论，获得点赞，并非常快地得到反馈。
And this, we think, has really changed what it means to be in. adolescent, what peer relationships might look like, teens' ability to connect with others, their sense of loneliness. And this is happening in both good and bad ways. And so we're trying to unpack what that means in terms of how they're able to stay connected to others, to find others who might share their similar interests. And ways that this may be increasing their sense of loneliness. or negative aspects on their body image.
我们认为，这真正改变了身为青少年的意义，改变了同伴关系的面貌，改变了青少年与他人连接的能力以及他们的孤独感。这正在以好的和坏的方式同时发生。因此，我们正试图剖析这意味着什么，包括他们与他人保持联系、寻找志同道合者的能力，以及这种方式可能如何增加他们的孤独感
The exciting piece that we're starting to explore, which we don't have data to share yet, is how this might be co-occurring with their brain development. So we know that the adolescent brain is highly sensitive to rewards. It's highly sensitive to social feedback. And so how might this interact with the ways that they're engaging in these online platforms and social, media and digital media context. And does the brain then get shaped by those experiences? Because
或对他们身体形象产生负面影响。令人兴奋的是，我们正开始探索一个我们尚无数据可分享的领域，即这可能如何与他们的大脑发育同时发生。我们知道青少年大脑对奖励高度敏感。它对社会反馈高度敏感。那么，这如何与他们在这些在线平台、社交媒体和数字媒体环境中互动的方式相互作用呢？大脑随后是否会被这些经历所塑造？因为
the brain itself is highly plastic and sensitive to its environment. The adolescent period is a huge time of brain development second only to that that we see in infancy. And so not only do we see this heightened sensitivity in terms of reward sensitivity and social sensitivity, but we see that the environment and things that teens are exposed to can shape further brain development. And so we don't yet know how these digital media platforms and what they're experiencing online might be integrated into their brains. So that's something that we're just very interested in exploring and are starting to conduct longitudinal research to follow teens across time and understand the bidirectional relationships
大脑本身具有高度的可塑性，并且对环境敏感。青春期是仅次于我们在婴儿期看到的大脑发育高峰期的又一个巨大时期。因此，我们不仅看到这种在奖励敏感性和社会敏感性方面升高的敏感性，而且我们看到环境以及青少年接触到的事物可以塑造进一步的大脑发育。因此，我们尚不清楚这些数字媒体平台以及他们在网上的经历将如何整合到他们的大脑中。所以这是我们非常感兴趣去探索的事情，并开始进行纵向研究，以跨时间追踪青少年并理解其中的双向关系。
here. So how is adolescents' neurobiological sensitivity affecting maybe how they engage online and vice versa? How is the way that they engage on these digital platforms shaping potential changes in brain development across time? I thought it was really interesting. And there was a recent Forbes article about your technology research and Jim Winston, whose foundation funds the center at UNC that you had. He said, a child born today and primarily raised on devices will be neurobiologically incapable of reading war and peace as an adult, not lazy or unmotivated. Incapable.
因此，青少年的神经生物学敏感性可能如何影响他们在网上的参与方式，反之亦然？他们在这些数字平台上互动的方式如何随着时间推移塑造大脑发育的潜在变化？我觉得这非常有趣。最近有一篇关于你的科技研究的福布斯文章，吉姆·温斯顿（Jim Winston）——他的基金会资助了你所在的北卡罗来纳大学中心——他说：今天出生并主要靠电子设备养大的孩子，成年后在神经生物学上将无法阅读《战争与和平》，这不是因为懒惰或缺乏动力。而是无法做到。
Do you agree with that? I mean, do we even know whether that's the case? I don't think we know. We definitely need empirical research that follows youth from childhood to adolescence into adulthood to be able to answer that question. question. We really don't have the data yet to even know how their use of digital media is impacting brain development and their ability to do things like read, War and Peace. And so we're just not there yet. We need much more research to be able to support those types of comments. And that's exactly what we're trying to do with our longitudinal research is to be able to
你同意这种说法吗？我的意思是，我们甚至知道事实是否真的如此吗？我认为我们并不知道。我们绝对需要从童年、青春期到成年进行追踪年轻人的实证研究，以便能够回答这个问题。我们确实还没有数据来了解他们对数字媒体的使用如何影响大脑发育以及他们做诸如阅读《战争与和平》之类事情的能力。所以我们还没到那个地步。我们需要更多的研究来支持这种类型的言论。这正是我们试图通过纵向研究来做的事情，以便能够
understand these mechanisms and how digital media might shape brain development, and of course, vice versa, for both good and bad ways. We don't know the positive and negative ways that this could be occurring because, like I said with the growing up too fast versus maturing more early, how that impacts brain development. It's the same thing with digital media. The brain is adapting to its environment. And so in a way, whatever the brain is doing to respond to these social inputs is adaptive, whether we qualify that as a good thing or bad thing, is subjective, I think. And so understanding these processes is going to take a lot of time because we need to do longitudinal research. And also, we need to take into context whether this is a good
理解这些机制，以及数字媒体如何塑造大脑发育，当然也包括反过来，无论是好是坏。我们不知道这可能以何种积极和消极的方式发生，因为就像我之前说的，关于过快长大与更早成熟如何影响大脑发育一样。数字媒体也是如此。大脑正在适应其环境。因此，在某种程度上，大脑为应对这些社会输入而做的任何事情都是适应性的，无论我们将其定性为好事还是坏事，我认为这都是主观的。因此，理解这些过程需要很长时间，因为我们需要进行纵向研究。此外，我们需要结合上下文来判断这究竟是好事还是坏事，因为其中很大一部分是基于我们认为青少年应该做什么或者我们认为这些结果如何影响他们发育的主观判断。还有什么你在现阶段试图回答的重大问题吗？
thing or bad thing, because much of it is subjective based on what we think adolescent should be doing or how we think these outcomes are impacting their development. Any other big questions that you're trying to answer at this point? I think that our main research is really just trying to unpack and answer a lot of the potential stereotypes that are out there. So we have work happening right now looking at peer influence. So we talked about this earlier, but also really considering the positive side of peer influence is one of our big goals. There is just as much evidence suggesting that peers can push
我认为我们的主要研究实际上只是试图剖析和回答外面存在的许多潜在刻板印象。因此，我们目前正在开展关于同伴影响的研究。所以我们之前讨论过这一点，但真正考虑同伴影响的积极方面是我们的宏大目标之一。有同样多的证据表明，同伴可以推动青少年参与非常好的行为并以更积极的方式改变他们的态度，正如相反的证据表明同伴会推动青少年承担更多风险一样。因此，这是我们渴望做出更多贡献的一个重要研究领域，并希望如果可能的话，用实证证据来揭穿这种观点，即青少年在互相怂恿参与更多消极和越轨行为，但实际上他们也在促进非常积极的行为。好吧，特尔泽博士，这非常有趣。非常感谢您今天加入我的节目。谢谢。非常感谢邀请我。
teens to engage in very good behaviors and change their attitudes in more positive ways as there is evidence on the contrary that peers drive teens to be more risky. And so this is a big area of research that we're eager to contribute to more and kind of debunk if we can with empirical evidence, this idea that teens are driving each other to engage in more negative and deviant behaviors, but actually are promoting very positive behaviors as well. Well, Dr. Telzer, this has been very interesting. I really appreciate you're joining me today. Thank you. Thank you very much for having me.
您可以阅读更多关于特尔泽博士的研究以及其他关于青少年大脑研究的文章，这些文章发表在七-八月号的美国心理学会杂志《心理学监视器》（Monitor on Psychology）上。您可以在我们的网站 www. speakingof psychology.org 上找到链接。您也可以在该网站上找到《心理学话题》以前的节目，或者在苹果、Stitcher或任何您获取播客的地方收听。如果您喜欢您听到的内容，
You can read more about Dr. Telzer's research and other research on the teenage brain in the July-August issue of APA's magazine Monitor on Psychology. You'll find a link on our website at www. speakingof psychology.org. You can also find previous episodes of Speaking of Psychology there or on Apple, Stitcher, or wherever you get your podcasts. And if you like what you hear,
请给我们留下一条评论。如果您对未来的播客有任何意见或想法，可以发电子邮件至 speaking of psychology at APA.org。《心理学话题》由李·温纳曼（Lee Wynerman）制作。我们的音频编辑是克里斯·康迪安（Chris Condyenne）。感谢您的收听。我是美国心理学会的金·米尔斯。本期节目暂无评论。点击转录文本中的任何句子即可发表评论。
please leave us a review. If you have comments or ideas for future podcasts, you can email us at speaking of psychology at APA.org. Speaking of psychology is produced by Lee Wynerman. Our sound editor is Chris Condyenne. Thank you for listening. For the American Psychological Association, I'm Kim Mills. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
请给我们留下评价。如果您对未来的播客有任何意见或想法，可以发送电子邮件至 speaking of psychology at APA.org。Speaking of psychology 由 Lee Wynerman 制作。我们的音频编辑是 Chris Condyenne。感谢您的收听。我是美国心理协会的 Kim Mills。本集目前还没有评论。点击文稿中的任意句子即可发表评论。